[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance on Russia Trump appears to be
running out of excuses he may also be
running out of time he is not however
running out of panic to developments
this week have underscored that the
first involves one of those excuses and
you guys are kidding right
General Michael Flynn who campaigned for
Trump who spoke at Trump's convention
who presumably guided the formation of
Trump's policy on Russia who was
communicating with the Russian
ambassador while on Trump's transition
team who Kellyanne Conway said still had
Trump's full confidence as of about 5:00
p.m. February 13th who resigned as
Trump's national security adviser at
11:00 p.m. February 13th who is in the
best case scenario merely guilty of
lying to Trump's vice president who was
offered to testify somewhere presumably
against Trump in exchange for immunity
he is Obama's fault uh-huh
I just heard where general Flynn got his
clearance from the Obama administration
Trump told CBS when he went to Russia it
was 2015 and he was on the Obama
clearance when general Flynn came to us
as you know he already had the highest
clearance you can have go on they're so
devastated because this only came up two
days ago I watched one of your other
competitors and they were devastated by
this news because you know what that
kills them that's the end of that
subject and then there was a ruling and
the ruling said Flynn wasn't my fault
and the ruling also said Flynn was
Obama's fault and so you can't ever talk
about Russia again because the ruling is
final it's a ruling and China ate my
homework what are you six
Trump mr. business mr. extreme betting
mr. full confidence in Flynn has just
admitted that when he brought Flynn on
he and his entire team his government in
waiting had no idea whether or not Flynn
had the necessary national security
clearance to become the national
security adviser or although he knows
Flynn traveled to Russia in 2015 on the
payroll of Kremlin propagandists to sit
alongside Vladimir Putin at the same
table with Jill Stein and truck knows
that Flynn was director of the Defense
Intelligence Agency until Obama's team
push
I'm out he seems to think the idea that
Flynn had gotten security clearance
while Obama was president means anything
Flynn did after Obama fired him is
somehow Obama's fault
Trump also believes literally believes
that the fact that Flynn worked for the
government while Obama was president
somehow ends the story about the growing
evidence of Trump's campaigns
connections to the Russian interference
with the 2016 election that kills them
he said that's the end of that subject
and this remarkable overconfidence
dovetails with the sudden return to
Trump's early campaign pledge to change
the laws so he can sue anybody who
writes a news story he doesn't like when
his henchmen ranked Priebus went on
ABC's this week the first story Priebus
use as an example of media
irresponsibility the only story previous
used as an example of media
irresponsibility was that same saga of
the Trump campaign and Russia I would
leave it to John Dean or a historian to
analyze the 12 stages of a massive
presidential political cover-up but
somewhere in them there has to be this
exact succession of emotions
first comes other panic at some
developments that might not be publicly
visible followed by a complete
rationalization that you had managed to
blame an outside party for it and we're
now and forever free followed in turn by
a public declaration that the subject
was now closed we saw this in Watergate
I believe the time has come to bring
that investigation and the other
investigations of this matter to an end
said Richard Nixon in his 1974 State of
the Union address one year of Watergate
is enough the Republicans applauded at
Nixon almost smiled and a note to mr.
Trump one week later the House voted 410
to four to authorize the judiciary
committee to investigate impeachment
charges against Nixon if we are in the
utter panic at some development that
might not be publicly visible stage of
cover-up what has caused it well --shoes
continued to drop at a steady pace two
of the shoes belong to sebastian Gorka
for to be leaving the White House he was
the guy who came up through the Fox News
Breitbart pipeline who showed up at one
of the inaugural balls as an incoming
Trump national security aide wearing
what might or what might not have been
the medal of a Hungarian group that was
pro-nazi during the second world war
more pertinently he was one of trumps
loudest defenders about Russia meanwhile
there is also a Russian shoe a Russian
national named Peter URI Vic levashov
has been indicted on eight counts in
Connecticut for according to the Justice
Department quote alleged operation of
the Calla house but net a global network
of tens of thousands of infected
computers which he allegedly used to
facilitate malicious activities the
former member of the British Parliament
Louise match who beat all of American
media by five months to the story that
the Justice Department had gotten a FISA
Court order relating to Trump's
associates
has now posted quote sources linked to
the intelligence community say it is
believed that a Russian hacker of the
election theater Levis EV was paid
directly by Boris Epstein on behalf of
both Trump and the FSB paid her lavish
off why that's Peter levy shafts name
the FSB is of course one of the many
Russian spy agencies Epstein is the
Russian born former Trump communications
team member who just left the White
House Mensch also quotes sources who say
that that botnet that levashov operated
had a command and control center in
Trump Tower and yes with Mensch and the
British agent Christopher Steele of the
steel dossier and the British newspaper
The Guardian leading world coverage on
this story and the BBC reporter Paul
wood who isn't far bide yes the British
are in this case your cousin who is just
far enough away to see clearly but your
girlfriend or boyfriend is really no
good and you need to get them out of
your life immediately and then there is
another shoe I would not ordinarily
mention it is a story from a man named
Claude Taylor who identifies himself on
Twitter as a quote veteran of three
presidential campaigns served on White
House staff parenthesis Clinton he
tweeted on Friday quote this just in
from a source with knowledge of commis
investigation
grand juries have convened and I know
that one is almost complete thin gruel
under ordinary circumstances but
Taylor's seeming bombshell was then
retweeted by a man named Rick Wilson
with just one word added quote same
Wilson is not just not a Democrat like
mr. Taylor is Wilson is a former Rudy
Giuliani admin and adviser he also
dreamed up the awful advertisement
linking Georgia senator Max Cleland to
Osama bin Laden in 2002 and he tied
then-senator Barack Obama to Reverend
Wright in 2007 take Wilson and Taylor
for whatever you think they are worth
but I am NOT ready to dismiss them
especially not after Taylor came back on
Sunday to describe one of the alleged
grand juries as having supposedly
focused on violations of the foreign
agents Registration Act
Rico racketeering and the Russians and
Trump Tower are their grand juries ready
to hand up hand down or hand out
indictments I would not dare claim to
know but I do know what I see Trump at
escalated levels of panic Trump floating
a constitutional amendment that would
keep us from talking about his Russia
problem Trump at the point of pretending
that a not very interesting detail about
General Michael Flynn and his security
clearance that Trump should have known
and anybody who'd ever thought about it
probably could have guessed is somehow
the final judgment on his entire Russia
problem that it quotes kills those
covering his Russia problem and
concludes for all time any discussion of
his Russia problem quoting him again
about his Russian problem that's the end
of the subject I do not dare to claim to
know the whole story of Trump and Russia
but I willingly dare to claim that this
is not the end of that subject resist
peace